je vais vous raconter quand même la saga
de la réforme des retraites a trop
longtemps et à la can 2010 cette réforme
systémique fusion de tous les régimes de
retraite un grand manitou jean paul
delevoye tout ça est abandonnée en rase
campagne en fait on ne fera rien ce sera
d'ailleurs le premier quinquennat depuis
2002 où il n'y aura aucun élément sur la
réforme des retraites qui est
indispensable si on veut sauver un des
points clés du système social système
par répartition et je dois dire que
réforme des retraites elle est aussi
nécessaire pour retrouver une forme d'
équilibre financier pour les comptes
publics que nous avons peut-être oublié
mais qui s'imposera nouveau que ça c'est
sérieux nous n'aurons qu'un seul
candidat ou une seule candidate c'est un
point sur lequel il y à un consensus
écoutez est-ce que ça c'est possible
mais le mardi là où la candidate il
devra de toute façon besoin du soutien
du parti il aura besoin du soutien de
ces réseaux de ce militant de son
financement donc j'allais dire tous les
candidats sont unanimes il faut
rassembler il faut proposer aux français
autre chose qu'une espèce de deux
batailles d'ego il faut donc avoir un ou
une candidate et être présent au
deuxième tour pour ne pas revenir dans
le duel mortifère à mes yeux pour la
démocratie qu'étalon choix entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen